arrival is a classically crafted slice
of sci-fi with a sublime performance by
Amy Adams at its core but how did the
filmmakers actually put the film
together in this video I'm going to look
at seven fascinating secrets you need to
know about the making of the movie the
Hebda pods spaceship owes its design to
an asteroid named after the Greek
goddess of Lauren legislation eunomia
during research for the design of the
alien crafts director denis villeneuve
came across the asteroid 15 eunomia was
attracted by what he called it's insane
shape like a strange egg and thought
that kind of pebble or oval shape would
bring a perfect sense of menace and
mystery to the hepta pod spacecraft
which in the film is made from materials
unknown to man and defies current human
scientific understanding in terms of how
it works and travels through space
octopuses whales elephants and even
spiders were all sources of inspiration
when it came to creating the aliens
Abbott and Costello Filner who wanted
their design to evoke a very strong
presence an air of intelligence and the
feeling of being close to a huge beast
underwater and he wanted to bring to
life the sort of surreal creature you
might imagine in a dream or nightmare
and in the later stages of the film he
wanted them to be suggestive of the Grim
Reaper on top of that it was important
to Vil nerve that the reveal of the full
alien body happened slowly over the
course of the film in order to build the
audience's suspense and intrigue and he
also wanted to contrast their quiet
arrival and calm communication with
Louise and Ian inside the ship with the
panicked reaction of the world outside
to achieve this he brought onboard
creature concept artist Carlos
one--there who worked on Ridley Scott's
Prometheus the underwater creatures like
octopuses and squid which so influenced
the hepta pods appearance also inspired
the filmmakers to use blasts of ink to
form their language while the idea that
the hepta pods nonlinear language should
consist of circles marked with twists
and curls came from screenwriter Eric
Heisler who even included rough sketches
of them in his script
the aliens language is an absolutely
crucial part of the film and Vilna have
wanted it to be striking almost
frightening completely distinct from
human language and suggestive of a
different mind set so high Sora's
concept was further developed by
production designer
trees ferment working with artist
Martine Bertrand whose idea it was for
the language to appear as abstract in
key circles that resembled coffee stains
the Mets and his team then immerse
themselves in the design process of
creating a fictional language that had
its own set of rules and was internally
accurate not just a randomly assembled
bunch of circles splotches and
flourishes in fact they created their
own dictionary with over a hundred
logograms
each of which conveys full sentences or
paragraphs and 71 of those were used in
the film dirty sci-fi is what Vil nerve
and his cinematographer Bradford Jung
called the look they created together
for a rival basically they wanted to
avoid the kind of spectacle you see in a
typical sci-fi blockbuster and instead
go for something more delicate and light
what that means for the film is that to
quote Bill nerve it feels like this was
happening on a bad Tuesday morning like
when you were a kid on the school bus on
a rainy day and you dream while looking
out the window at the clouds that kind
of atmosphere and a major influence on a
rivals very raw and naturalistic look
for cinematographer Bradford Young was
the work of Scandinavian photographer
Martina Hoagland even of especially the
subdued and mysterious quality of her
exhibition and book Speedway the film
arrival that we see today is very
different than it was originally going
to be as its whole structure was changed
in post-production
according to ville nerve while the
original screenplay made sense on paper
the visual medium of cinema made telling
a nonlinear story with a twist like a
rival much more challenging and when the
director got into the editing room he
realized to be told to film exactly as
it wasn't the script its structure
wouldn't be dynamic enough it would feel
repetitive in places and there would be
some discrepancies within the characters
fortunately Arrivals editor Joe Walker
came to the rescue and suggested
restructuring the footage they'd shot in
a less linear fashion which also meant
that the very structure of the film
would reflect some of the movie's main
themes one of the only Hollywood studios
that showed any interest in making a
rival when the script was initially
pitched to them actually wanted a male
protagonist to replace the film central
character linguist dr. Louise Banks who
by the way is also the lead in the short
story the films based on however the
movies producers stuck to their guns and
the film independently and later with
Amy Adams attached they sold the rights
to distribute the film in North America
to Paramount for a record sum of twenty
million dollars at Cannes Film Festival
in 2014 interestingly enough before the
role of dr. banks an arrival came along
Adams had been planning to take some
time away from making movies and just
hang out with her family however when
she read the screenplay she fell in love
with the story and the opportunity to
work with denis villeneuve was also too
much for draw to turn down originally
the film was named after Ted Chang short
story but directed an evil nerve decided
to change the film's title from story of
your life because he felt that audiences
would think the film was a rom-com
rather than a sci-fi movie and because
he believed they'd moved away from the
short stories focus indeed to increase
the film's drama and tension the
screenplay made some significant changes
to the original tale for example the
script added global conflict by having
the aliens arrive in a dozen locations
on earth which in turn kicked off a
ticking clock scenario and in the end
after considering hundreds of potential
titles the filmmakers actually settled
on the very first one they thought of
arrival now I'd love to know your
favorite moment in arrival and how you
think the film compares with your
favorite sci-fi movies let me know your
thoughts in the comments below plus if
you'd like to talk about the film in
more detail I've got a full spoilery
analysis in my arrival explained video
which you can check out and the link to
the left and if you're a sci-fi fan you
might also like my interstellar video
with 15 cool facts about the making of
that movie you can watch that by
clicking over there on the right if you
enjoyed this video do please like share
and subscribe thanks for watching and
see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers